jetzt polizei für meinen ersten gast die
grünen freitags kommen die fachfrau für
bairische sprache und bayerische kultur
claudia pichler
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so
freut sich sehr schön der stoff ist mir
wirklich ja nichts weiter heißt ja ganze
sendung deine 150 und für mich ist es
sehr spannend man sie sagen wir
inzwischen
beeinflusst die ja schon seit 17 jahren
jetzt wirklich die bayerische kultur und
die bayerische sprache
ja damals gar nicht so genannt weil du
hast zum beispiel ganz neue wörter
geschöpft als jetzt so im bereich
beschimpft wird das zb also man in
bayern sagt nein wieso denn was
irgendwie total schief läuft haben alle
gesagt direkt dritter aber du hast die
es nur gesteigert genau ist so viel mehr
dreck trecker treck
ettlinger baut aggressionen ab